- If one person listening to this podcast
tomorrow sets up a meeting
with their actual boss
and actually delivers what's on their mind
that may save them for being
able to stay in a company
they actually like a lot of things of.
(rock music playing)
- [Gary] The GaryVee Audio Experience.
Podcast friends, how are you?
Very excited about this.
As all of you know, I'm
not doing a whole lot of
original interviews these days.
Kind of busy, head down,
but very special guest here.
In a second, I'll let Beth
really introduce herself
in her own words, and I'll go
into a series of questions.
But this has been a long one in the making
that I'm excited about, and hopefully
a lot of people get a
lot of value out of it.
So without further ado,
Beth, why don't you take the floor
for three or four minutes here
and give everybody a
little 411 on what you
and your sister and organization do.
A little bit about yourself,
and then we'll go into some Q and A.
- All right, sure.
Hi, Gary.
Hi, everyone listening.
I'm Beth Weissenberger,
co-founder with my youngest sister
Lauren Zander of Handel Group.
We built Handel Group 17 years ago
and it was our first year like,
"Is there such a thing as
executive life coaching?"
17 years ago, we were made fun of,
we were not, you know, the first question
out of everyone's mouth
is, "Are you a doctor?"
And we're like, "Yeah. No, we're not.
We are executive life coaches."
And we gave ourselves a year
to see if we could build a company or not.
And here it is 17 years later,
we're the largest executive
life coaching company
and we have about 70
people who work for us.
And I coach C-suite executives like Gary.
So yes, I am Gary Vee's coach.
And about 21, 22 other executives,
leadership executives in his org,
and then about total of
about 500 people are engaged
in the coaching in one way or another
through Inner.U or one-on-one coaching.
And that is what I do for a living
is I go into companies,
triple their businesses
and raise the bar of humanity
and learning to human better
with all the people that we coach.
So that's me in a nutshell.
- Prior to you and your
sister going into this,
let's go back to little Beth.
I was like, little, you know
just to paint pictures for the audience.
Like what kind of girl
were you growing up?
Like creative? Were you athlete?
Were you student? Where'd did you grow up?
Give us a little context, I wanna get to
I wanna do three minutes
to the moment of you and your sis.
And then we'll go into, you
know, executive coaching
and common themes.
- Sure.
- We have a lot of entrepreneurs,
a lot of executives who listen to this.
So I want to spend a lot
of this on common themes
and I'll go into, you know,
one of the breakthroughs, no question
that I think you've been
instrumental in for Vayner, me.
But let's go a little
bit further back, like-
- So my childhood, yes.
- Yes.
- So I was raised
So I'm 62 years old.
I'm the oldest of three other siblings.
My brother Matthew, my sister
Marnie and sister Lauren.
We were raised, as I said,
Orthodox Jews in Long Island.
So I'm from the Five Towns Lawrence.
None of the four children
turned out Orthodox Jews.
We honor spirituality
and I dig being Jewish.
(Gary laughs)
But about as far as it goes,
my father is 85, still
a modern Orthodox Jew,
mother never really was.
Shhh...
She told us that a secret she was keeping
for 50 years is that she never cooked
you know, you're not supposed to eat
dairy and meat together.
And my mother said,
confessed to my father,
"Oh, I always cooked with dairy and milk.
It would only make it better."
And all he could do was spit his food up,
he laughed because what's he gonna do?
They're 85 years old now.
- I love it.
- I was an athlete, I was
number one on my tennis team,
you know, in high school
volleyball team, track meet,
I did all of that.
When I was older, my daughter had me
start riding horses at 50-years-old.
So I rode for eight years.
- That's awesome.
- And now, I water ski.
My boyfriend made me get up on water ski.
So I do that too.
- What about from a student
or entrepreneurial lens?
Were you horrible?
- Bad girl.
Do not anyone-
My lesson in life was
if I could do it again,
I would do it better.
You know in high school I had to.
I was punished by my parents brutally
if I didn't get B pluses.
Anything less than a B, no sleepovers,
no phone calls, you know.
- Same for me.
- Right? So I was bru-
- I was punished constantly.
- Oh, yeah. I was-
- I was grounded literally
from fourth grade
to senior year of high school.
I stayed grounded.
- Yeah, mine was, although I
never tell the accurate story
'cause I used to say, "My
mother used to hit me."
Which she did, but my
mother had five rules.
The fifth rule was if
you don't follow the four
I'm gonna sock you.
So she-
(Gary laughs)
I was the rebel.
I was like, "Yeah, eff you,
I ain't listening into you."
And so I in high school,
obviously I wanted sleepovers and a phone.
So I kept the promise of B plus and-
- By the way, for all the
kids that are listening
the phone was not the mobile phone.
It was-
- No.
- having access to-
- The rotary-
(voices overlapping)
bring it downstairs and
plug it in the basement
so no one could hear you, right?
And then college, I finished
I started University of
Michigan and finished at NYU.
I studied to be an actress.
Never did that.
- How was Michigan?
Was that a fun experience? Or did-
- It was a ton of fun
Year and a half
I was there for a year.
I did college in three years.
So a year and a half there, loved it.
It was fucking cold as goddamn hell.
But you know, I loved the football
and I loved all that stuff.
I got out of the small
town and got far away
from my parents.
And then I came back to
NYU and graduated there.
- Is that because you
want to do to actress life
and you needed to be in New York?
- I was gonna be an actress, and
Daddy, I need to be at NYU, right?
So, you know, spoiled.
Total
(Gary laughs)
Spoiled brat that I was.
And you know, my poor dad.
I have apologized and I would
never do it this way again.
- And just for my own fun,
'cause now I'm enjoying myself here.
When did you, when did you
realize actress life was not-
how quickly into that
journey did that happen?
- That, I ended that at about 21-
I graduated college and then I got into
the whole world of
humaning and transformation
and wanting to save the people.
And so I left acting right away.
- Interesting.
- Yeah.
- What...Talk to me about your sis
because I know this offline a little bit
your sis came, was doing her thing.
Like give me a- there's a lot of-
- Lauren Zander is 11
years younger than me.
She is, no kidding,
The genius.
She is the chairman to my
vice chairman in the company.
I'm running the company day-to-day.
She is my boss. Deserves to be my boss.
And she invented all the
method that we're teaching
at Vayner Media and you know, and
and all the different
companies, live nation
and insurance companies,
is all my sister's
method that she invented.
And then I took it and figured out
how to get it grounded and sold,
you know, to clients.
Big ones.
- Talk to me about
Let's jump around here a little bit.
So, tell us, you know,
she comes with this stuff.
You guys sit down.
You decide to start this business.
- Yup.
- A lot of people who listen to this
also want to be in the service business.
Like, "Hey, hire me to do X."
Whether that's be an NFT artist right now
whether that's to be a
content creator, a consultant.
How did you get your first clients?
(Beth chuckles)
- It's called rainmaking,
baby, it's rainmaking.
You know, my sister and
I are rainmakers, right?
So, you know, we were not
we had a method, my
sister's method, right?
And then we were just, we had a Rolodex.
We did not believe in cold calling.
We did not believe,
"Let me go cold call all the
LinkedIn connections I got."
We're not that gang, right?
Like you, you meet us.
You love us.
You want our method.
We're getting in.
And so we really were,
all our relationships is who we
you know, went and spoke to.
And when we got our first
big corporate client
we then knew we had to deliver
and we tripled his business
and then it just became word of mouth.
We're still in the word of mouth business
in the company that we're in.
I'm not gonna have people cold call.
I'm not that girl, right?
So it's all relationship building.
So I get my job done with you, Gary Vee
and then someone's going to
recommend or hear about that.
And then they want to know,
"Can you do that for my company?"
- Of course.
- It's always worked like that.
- So literally again
because what I tried to
use this platform for
is really help the
people on the other side.
- Okay.
- You believe, 17 years of success
that when you have a quality product
if you're able to, you know
remember,
you and your sis had a roll of decks
to kind of tap into from your years
of doing whatever you were doing.
In the past, you were able
to kind of land, you know,
in that, in that networking
of the people that you've had
relations with, both of you.
You were able to get one
of those several dozens
of people to say yes.
You were able to execute.
Thus, it created leverage for
word of mouth going forward.
- Yes.
- You're...what would
you say to the person
that's listening right now and saying,
"Beth, I've got the chutzpah like you
me and my sister, just like you guys,
but we're both 25.
And we really don't have
that much of a Rolodex."
Thoughts on that? Just out of curiosity.
- Yeah, one thing that
we believe that we did.
Right? Like what got us into MIT.
So we wanted to make a
difference in the whole
university world, education world,
help the students, help
the administrators.
And so one of the ways that
we worked is we would go,
"Hey Gary, you're a professor at MIT.
We knew that this professor
happened to want to get married
and had an awful love life."
My sister said, "All right,
I'll coach you on my dime.
Get you married.
You get me into MIT."
And they made that deal and we got in.
Same way we got into Stanford
and we teach there for credit now.
Right? Same way
And most of the corporations
in the beginning that I got in
I would either with the
president or the head of HR, your
you know, your chief
human resource officer
or someone accountable
for marketing, I go,
"Let me give you 30 minutes or an hour.
You see, and then tell me
if you want to bring us in."
So we-
- Stay there for a second.
One thing that I hear
a lot about is people
demonizing free work.
And, and you just, you don't put it
on a pedestal, curious to, you know,
I'm sure you've seen this
over the last five to seven,
10, 15 years.
There's a lot of conversations like
never do spec work, never do free work.
It doesn't seem like, you
know, I'm not on that camp.
- Yeah, no.
If you're 25-years-old
and you say you have a product that rocks
and you want in my business?
I'm not going to pay for it.
I don't know you, you
don't come with anything.
So give me a trial.
And then if I love it, I'm
gonna, I'm going to want it.
I'm going to tell my
other people about it.
So we were never-
- And what do you say to people-
- And that's how I got
some of my biggest NFL players
was like, "Eh, let me give you."
I don't want-
they all think I'm going
to come for your money.
No, I'm gonna give you two free sessions.
And if you like what I just
gave you, then you buy.
If you don't like what I gave
you, what's the big deal?
You got two free sessions.
I met an NFL player.
I made a difference.
But guess what?
Every NFL player that I ever gave
two free coaching sessions to?
My clients.
- Beth, what about the
people who took free sessions
and didn't become clients?
What do you say to people-
- God bless!
I send them away with love.
They don't either have the money.
What I did, they didn't like.
Who cares?
That was 30 minutes out
of my frigging life,
maybe an hour out of my entire
life that I gave it away.
I believe it-
Sorry. It's weird.
But I believe in paying it forward.
You pay it forward, it's coming back.
Now I don't pay it
forward to 'get it back'.
But why wouldn't I do that?
Like, if I wanna start in the-
if I wanna build a sports division
and I've never done that before,
like I could say,
"Well it translates from
business to sports."
No, I know it does, but
the athlete doesn't.
So let me just do this for you.
And I, that's how we started
our business and it worked.
And here we are.
- For the individuals who
who
have companies.
- Yep.
- And have six, 12, 22, 212 employees.
Let's rattle off in this podcast
themes that you see that are common.
I don't want to say universal
'cause every situation is different
but there's a lot of commonalities-
- Yep.
- in these things.
What are some of the things
that you see that are common
in companies that lead to bad cultures
or vulnerabilities or limited growth or
(indistinct)
- Well, I'm going to say one of yours,
You ready?
- I'm ready.
- All right.
So I know you gave your culture a B minus.
And so once, you know
we raised the bar and now it's a B minus.
Okay. Far out.
So then what's in there?
And so last week, I
did a session with Nick
and a bunch of his SVPs
on removing gossip from the workplace.
- Yep.
- Gossip is one of the main culprits that
if you do not remove it from
your culture and then put in
how do you have hard conversations.
So we can talk about client candor
but you gotta teach people,
how do you do candor?
Right? Like if I'm not going
to gossip and talk about
you know, go to somebody
who can't do anything
about it and tell you crap.
Right? I gotta take that out.
But then I gotta teach you
go have the courage to
go have the conversation
whether it's with Gary Vee,
whether it's with this
executive or this person.
So gossip is one of the main
culprits in an organization.
- Give me- I love that.
And I couldn't agree more.
Give me a couple more
because I really want people
to leave here with like,
"Huh, that is going on
in my shop." You know?
What are-
Talk to me about-
Actually, let me throw a
couple of things at you.
And then you'll add.
What about insecurity of upper management?
When you hear that, how does
that play out in your mind?
- So if someone comes
to me, who's like ins-
has a whole negative
dialogue about the leadership
before I'm gonna go anywhere
near the leadership,
You know, I really do
believe in accountability.
So what is this human, why
is this human sitting around
complaining to themselves
and likely other people
about they're not digging on
the leadership. All right?
Well what the frick
are you doing about it?
So I would start with their
being what we call a chicken
and avoiding the conversations.
I would then help them
to stop being a chicken
and script the conversation
that they have to
go have with leadership, right?
Like, so if you've got your
junior people talking trash
about the leaders, it's twofold.
You got junior people being chickens
not able to go speak to them.
And then leaders, why do
you have people so scared
of you that they can't come talk to you?
So it works both ways.
They don't feel safe enough to go up
and then I'd have to talk to the up-
the leaders - and go,
what are you doing not making
it safe enough for people to
come to you to let you
know what's not working?
- But from your perspective
all these years, what pers-
this is such an arbitrary question
and you'll do your best to answer it.
But I'm really just fascinated.
What percentage of companies do you think
are being led by fear?
And what percentage of companies
do you think are being led
by optimism and offense and
trying to eliminate fear?
Just from your perspective
through the years,
I'm just curious all the
doors that you've walked in-
- You see, I think no matter
in every company I've been in
and like I've told you, I
loved that you had created
in your culture, The Honey Empire, right?
But we had to deal with that
it was a lot of honey and not
a lot of, you know, candor.
- Which, to your point earlier,
the big breakthrough you've done for
me, which has, is a really
important part like this,
this term 'kind candor'.
And to your point, now we
have to operationalize it.
But even in standing up
and having an entire company
meeting and explaining
to everyone, you know,
back to accountability,
"Hey, I have very big
ambitions for our culture."
We've done a lot of
things, right by standards.
One of the biggest compliments in my
23 years of operating was your assessment
when you came in and said,
"Hey, you actually have a lot
of good shit going on here."
You know?
And our entitlement and our, you know
my inability and this
always blows my fans' minds.
I always tell them.
I'm like, "Public figure
me, great at candor,
because there's no human
on the other side".
I'm speaking into truths, right?
I'm speaking on stage.
- Right.
- So Gary Vee, brings a
lot of value to people
candor-wise, but Gary Vaynerchuk the CEO
really struggled, you know.
And through another part of my life
I was able to realize
my dad's negative vessel
to delivering candor was
what I was not fond of.
The energy of the candor
but I had to take years
to separate the vessel
from the actual thing.
Candor,
and the way that I've tried
to position it, kind candor
I think, is now an essential element
of our culture and is moving us up.
We needed that bad, and it's
really made a huge impact,
but I think it's always
interesting to see what
commonalities and
shortcomings companies have.
- Yeah, let me give you another one.
- Please.
- So another one is,
and again, in your culture
and I'm starting to work
on it with your executives
and will with you in our
coaching session tomorrow
is that the language of accountability.
So Gary Vee, you got a language for sure,
for
wine, right?
So like there's languages.
I don't have any language for wine.
I go, "Hmm, I like it.
Hmm, I don't like it."
It's the extent of my language.
The language of accountability
is very important.
In fact, I think that's what'll impact
the empire side of your Honey Empire.
What I mean by the
language of accountability
first and foremost, is the ability
to own when you're not gonna
keep a frigging promise.
That does not make you
a bad person at all.
It depends on how you own it
when you just blew a promise.
So if you blow a promise,
I don't want to hear,
"Gary, I didn't what I
said 'cause you know,
this happened and then this
and they didn't return my email and then-"
So there's no, there's just,
"Hi. I know I said I would do that.
I didn't do it.
That is clearly unacceptable.
Here's what I'll do about it.
Here's when it will be done.
And did I mess your-
- Or feeling comfortable
in even saying, you know
"I'm a little concerned that I'm not
gonna be able to deliver on this."
- Exactly.
On Wednesday before the
deliverable is due on Friday.
Even though I know you're
hoping you will get it done
and that you won't get in trouble.
Well, no one then says on Wednesday,
"Okay, listen. I'm a bit- I'm behind.
A mess.
This is due Friday.
It's not going to happen.
Here's what I'm going to do about it.
Did that mess you up?"
Et cetera.
So there's a language of
owning when you're not
gonna do what you said.
Even the CEO, Gary.
Every CEO is allowed to change their mind.
You could have said-
- I love changing my mind.
- Right, I know you do, but you-
(Beth laughs)
- And I do, I mean-
- I know, but you have to be able to
own it rather than explain it
'cause at the end of the day
no one wants to friggin'
hear your explanation
about why you just freakin'
changed your mind again
or not gonna do what you said.
They just want to be able to hear,
"Beth, listen. I know I told
you I was going to do that.
Not going to do it.
Now I know that messes with you
but here's what I'm gonna do about it."
Boom, boom, boom.
And then let them speak.
So there's a language of accountability
that's missing in most companies.
- Love that.
Beth, how many people
end up leaving companies that were
actually good jobs for them
strictly because they were unable
to have the proper conversation?
You know, when I think about
all the people that have left,
I get it on the receiving end.
I get people that email
four or five years later
that regret leaving because
they didn't take care
of one little thing that
became a big thing, you know?
And by the way, by the way,
I have enough self-awareness
and accountability to know
that if I didn't have the luxury
of being a CEO and being a business owner,
my lack of wanting to have
confrontation and candor
would've meant that I've
probably would have been
that kind of employee.
That, fuck. Things are- it's
easier for me to move on.
Than to address- I mean,
I think I'd think about it
in a lot of parts of my life when I would
you know, why I broke up
with girlfriends as a kid
when it could have been addressed
but because I didn't want to address it.
- Yeah.
- So when you hear me
frame up that question
'cause I'm trying to think of what
There's a far majority of people
that are listening right
now that are employees
that have little micro problems.
And I just think that whole framework
that you and your sis
have around the chicken
could be stunningly impactful on-
if one person listening to this podcast
tomorrow sets up a meeting
with their actual boss
and actually delivers
what's on their mind.
That may save them for being
able to stay in a company
they actually like a lot of things of
- Yeah.
- I feel that a lot of people
leave a lot of companies or
let a seed become cancer because-
- No, for sure.
- Please.
- Yeah, let me address it.
So it's actually, and I've
done this with a bunch
of your people.
It's in Inner.U, in module seven.
It's called career haunting.
- Why don't you tell everybody how you
expanded your business to not
just be human, but platform.
- Yeah. So, so let me
let me answer this and then I'll tell you.
So this is, I'm speaking about everyone
Inner.U, which is our online
coaching module, 12 modules.
So Inner.U, life, career, love, student.
We have different ones,
but in module seven in the career one,
it's a career haunting.
Now what's a career haunting?
It's something that happened.
So let's say however old you are
you've had a million experiences.
And when we ask you for
your career haunting
let's say you've got five to 10 of them.
The question is, why does that haunt you?
And the other 999,000 experiences don't.
Because, the way you tell
that story has a lie in it
or you didn't learn the right lesson.
So the- and most people
the right lesson is
speak up, use your voice.
Why did you let that person do that to you
when you didn't say anything
and then they leave the job?
And you learn the wrong lesson called,
Hello, use your voice.
Go ask your boss.
Why did you do that when you
said you were going to do this?
Like there's a conversation.
And so, the hauntings
will keep happening to you
in your life over and over until
you learn the right lesson.
- Beth, how-
When people come to you and say,
"Beth, I hear you.
You shoot it straight.
I love this, that, you
know, Long Island vibe"
(indistinct)
you and Gary spent, you know
if they hit you up on
social or some (indistinct)
You guys spent a ton of
time on shooting it straight
and the candor thing, which makes sense
because that was such
a big framework for us
where we had strengths.
But this was a weakness, but
fuck that.
You two were wrong.
I shoot it straight all the time.
And I'm always getting in trouble.
I'm always getting fired.
- Yeah.
- For the person who's
listening here, that
(Beth laughs)
- I gotcha
- Yeah, 'cause I think it's going to help.
Because I've noticed that-
Let me finish this,
'cause I think you got me
but I want to make sure everybody gets it.
For the person that hears this and says,
Well, this is the wrong advice.
I've had a very difficult
time in my career
'cause I've been fired multiple times
because the boss doesn't
actually wanna hear the truth.
(indistinct)
What's the common mistake
for the person that
finds themselves candorous?
What are they missing?
- You're missing empathy.
You're missing the kindness side.
You're missing your heart.
You can't hit somebody upside the head
with a brick with no heart.
You'll leave 'em bloody.
So even though your
message might be accurate
if you do it with a
punch, with no kindness
and no empathy and no
caring about the human,
Hi, you kinda deserved the smack.
Right? So-
- Easy for people who are
bosses or leaders or owners,
Thoughts for the people.
A lot of times I find
that employees don't feel
they need to do that because the machine,
the bosses, have the leverage.
Do you, you know I've noticed,
I've tried to coach and
talk to a lot of like,
I'm like, "Look, just because yes,
you're a junior employee
bricks still make bosses bleed too."
Correct? Incorrect?
What are your thoughts?
- Oh, you can't, you'll get
It's disrespect.
I'm the boss.
I'm gonna feel disrespected, right?
And, or that you're not loyal
or whatever the pet
peeve is for that boss.
There's no, you don't ever
wanna disrespect someone.
It's always, how can I let you know
what isn't working for me, from my heart?
So you can hear me, right?
And then we can have a conversation.
People, it's not, you know,
your boss, your manager
they care about you.
I know you've come up with
whatever story you now believe
and gathering evidence for,
but you're gathering evidence
and you're gonna be
walking right out the door.
So the main principle is
whatever you believe, you prove.
If you believe your boss doesn't like you
you're gonna keep proving it.
And therefore you won't go speak to them.
So you don't wanna get stuck
with that belief because
likely it's not true
even though you're
gathering evidence for it.
- The last three minutes in this podcast
I wanna give you the platform.
A, how can people find you?
Because I know plenty well.
B, what did we not touch on
that you'd love to touch on?
- Okay, great. Thanks Gary.
- Of course.
- Everyone, you can
find me at Handel Group
Beth, B-E-T-H
@handelgroup
H-A-N-D-E-L group.com.
And then you can just shoot
me an email or a note.
You can find me on Instagram, HandelGroup.
You'll see all our content.
And go on there because we
drop content all the time
that you can listen to
myself, or any one of
my coaches and help you
whether it's in a, you
know, you'll see, like today
I'm going to be doing boundaries
around saying yeses and nos.
And then the other thing,
everyone, of course
for Gary's listeners, and
Gary's got about 500-ish people
in this program, it's called Inner.U.
It's our online coaching
modules, our coaching course.
And for the listeners
you can get Inner.U LIFE
for half off, up until March 31st.
So for $325,
it is a genius course.
It's our whole entire coaching program.
And you get one free
coaching session with it,
not me but one of my coaches.
And use the coupon, GaryVee.
- Who should they ask for
on the one coaching thing?
- No, you're not (indistinct)
- Okay, got it. All right,
just having a little fun.
- But the coupon, GaryVee,
to get the half off.
- Okay, you created something?
So there's a GaryVee for that?
- There's a GaryVee coupon.
- Thank you.
- Absolutely.
- Very nice.
- Yes. All right.
I'm coming for you
tomorrow in your coaching.
- I know, I'm looking forward to it.
Team, everybody's listening.
Look,
I in another life
will be able to have Beth
and her sister's job.
I love this shit.
And I think that for me through the years
I've been able to do a
ton of this stuff insular
but there's just something
so incredible with
different terminology, different
voices, different energies.
It's like anything in life.
And I think the more
everybody starts to expand
on that awareness.
No matter how good you have
it, it's like anything else.
It's good, but there's
always, it's like a seesaw.
There's always the other
things that come along
with that good.
In Vaynerland over the last 20 years
it's been really good by macro comparison
but candor was an
incredibly important one.
And standing up the term 'kind candor'
made it even more palpable and scaled
and there's plenty of more things
but that's for an instance.
So, hope everybody
continues on their journey.
Beth, thank you so much.
You and the Handel Group
for the impact you've had
on our org, other orgs.
And I hope this podcast leads
to a couple other people getting
getting some advancements
in their journey.
I know you're in Costa Rica,
so go enjoy the weather.
Thank you for being on.
Bye bye.
Thank you so much.
- Bye everybody.
- YouTube watcher, what's up?
It's Gary Vee.
First of all, thank you so much.
I hope you're doing super
well during these times.
I also want to ask you
please subscribe
because my commitment and
exploration of YouTube
is about to explode stories, polls
more content, more engagement,
more surprise and delight.
This, is the time to subscribe.
I hope you consider it.
And I hope I see you soon.